[archive audio] Why? Why must man go into
space?
Why must he attempt this new and forbidding
environment?
Space, with its belts of radiation, meteorites,
solar winds, unknown cosmic forces.
To explore his world man has always risked
the unknown,
because it is unknown, and man's nature is to know.
Project Mercury is a beginning for man, in
space.
[narration] Mercury: the mythological God
of travel,
was the name chosen for the US's maiden space
programme,
which was established in 1959, shortly after
the formation of the civilian space body,
NASA.
Defining the goal was simple: to send a man
into space and bring him back safely.
But NASA was under no illusions that achieving
this would be simple.
Just two years previously the US had watched
with shock and embarrassment as the Soviets
placed Sputnik 1, the first artificial satellite,
into earth orbit.
And against the backdrop of an ever-escalating
tension between the two nations, the Space
Race was born.
The ultimate goal: to claim the title of first
in placing a man on the moon.
The Cold War had seen a boom in the military's
development of long-range rocket technology.
With the clock ticking, NASA didn't have the
luxury of time to develop new rocket systems
from the ground-up.
So instead, it turned to the military's existing
arsenal of ballistic missiles.
Two rocket systems were chosen.
The first was the Redstone rocket, to be used
for Mercury's short-range sub-orbital missions,
which involved sending sending payloads into
space, but not sending them into orbit.
For this, the more powerful Altas D rocket
was selected.
These rockets were designed to carry munitions,
so NASA needed to develop a capsule system
to carry the human payload and return them
to Earth safely.
In the event of an emergency, these capsules
were designed to separate and carry their
pilot away.
[archive audio] The escape rocket takes the
capsule away from the booster.
From all of the active duty pilots from the
navy, marines and air force,
the service records of 473 test pilots were
selected for...
[narration] Perhaps more important to Project
Mercury's goals was the selection and training
of the men who were going to pilot the rockets.
[archive audio] The graduate of an AV or air
force test pilot school, 1500 hours of flight
time, qualified in jet aircraft, an engineering
background, younger than 40 at the time of
selection, and 5 feet 11 or less,
[narration] The candidates underwent intensive
physical and mental assessments.
[archive audio] Each measurable reaction of
body chemistry, each physical function was
measured, probed, diagnosed. What is the specific...
[narration] Women were automatically excluded
due to President Eisenhower's insistence on
recruiting from the pool of active military
test pilots.
[archive audio] 7 men emerged from this competitive
purgatory as the Project Mercury astronauts.
[narration] The so-called Mercury Seven were
soon paraded in front of the world,
thrust into the national spotlight, becoming
the poster boys for the newly established
American space programme.
Over the coming years the press and US public
would take great interest not only in the
progress of Project Mercury, but in the personal
pursuits of these budding astronauts,
digging into their private lives, and presenting
them as national heroes.
[archive audio] Here the National Aeronautics
and Space Administration space task group
under the direction of Robert Gilruth had
organised a training programme for the astronauts.
They were excellent students and had a realistic
and tough minded approach to Project Mercury.
They had to know all the answers, here they
discovered...
[narration] Project Mercury's manned missions
featured only a single pilot, sot he 7 would
have to work alone under the harsh g-force
profiles of launch and re-entry,
along with the uncomfortable temperatures,
confined spaces, and quirks of weightlessness.
Before any of the astronauts could put this
training into practice, NASA would have to
ensure the rocket hardware was up to scratch.
So 20 unmanned developmental missions were
launched before any of the Mercury Seven strapped
into a launch capsule.
A number of these missions involved sending
animals into space, including Ham, the first
space-faring chimpanzee,
who was sent into space and returned safely
in January 1961.
And Enos, the first chimp to orbit earth in 1962.
Preparations for missions started a month
in advance, with two men chosen to take part,
one as the primary astronaut, the other as
the backup.
On 5 May 1961 the US sent its first man into
space.
Launching Alan Shepard 116 miles above the
Earth on a 15 minute sub-orbital mission,
retrieving him safely from the Atlantic Ocean
shortly after launch.
Project Mercury saw a total of six manned missions,
achieving its first orbital flight
with John Glenn in February 1962.
Gordon Cooper brought the programme to a close
in 1963 with a 34-hour orbital flight, achieving
22 orbits.
Although the US had achieved impressive feats
with Project Mercury, the Soviets had beaten
them at nearly every step.
[archive audio] Newspaper headlines tell the
story: Gherman Titov of Russia returns to
earth after orbiting the globe 17 times in
a little more than 25 hours, covering...
[narration] Yuri Gagarin had achieved a successful
orbital flight a whole month before Shepard's
first sub orbital mission.
A year later, in 1962, Andriyan Nikoliev completed
a 4 day orbital stint aboard Vostok 3,
far outstripping any mission on the Mercury
roster.
It was beginning to dawn on the American people
that they were losing this race.
And so in 1962 Kennedy hit back with a rallying
call:
[archive audio] For the eyes of the world
now look into space,
to the moon and to the planets beyond,
and we have vowed
that we shall not see it governed
by a hostile flag of conquest,
but by a banner of freedom
and peace.
We have vowed that we shall not see space
filled with weapons of mass destruction,
but with instruments of knowledge
and understanding.
Yet the vows of this nation
can only be fulfilled if we in this nation
are first,
and, therefore, we intend to be first.
[narration] By pitching America's quest for
space as a fight for peace and security,
Kennedy had enlivened the nation's ambition.
But it would have to dig deep into its pockets
and cover significant ground if it were to
beat its rivals to the top spot.
All eyes were now set firmly on the moon.
[archive audio]We choose to go to the moon
in this decade and do the other things,
not because they are easy, but because they
are hard.